you tell me too good about yourself who
you are where you came from
can you tell me your name I can't
remember a day one greenie rise and
shine
what is this place walk sit lady don't
put us here we don't know what's - there
you guys can't just keep me here I can't
let you leave why will you tell me
what's out there
it's the mains
every one when those doors open the
runners look for a way out
and no one has ever survived a night in
the maze what happens to
we clean Grievous we don't belong here
somebody built the mace I think it's
time we find out what we're really up
against you now let the others get
curious
how's that this is the first real clue
you found him
who knows where this might lead us
to go
Thomas
everything started changing the moment
you showed up what if we were sent here
for a reason the doors are closing
here they're gonna keep coming back
until they kill us all
we get out now or we die trying
you don't get it we're already dead
sure about this no
I can't leave they won't let us
you